what's up welcome to wonderful the
Wednesday my name is Samuel leaves and
this week I've got two fantastic guys
they are from Hong Kong and then become
financially free quit their jobs now
move to England absolutely killing it
so please welcome onto the show Ken and
Joseph good to have you guys with us
Thank You Samuel
thanks Lisa so you you came to the crash
course and you you were those people I
always say if you've come from overseas
let me know where you're at and you said
we've come from Hong Kong so tell us a
little bit about why did you come to the
crash course in the first place and why
did you want to get into property yeah
maybe I got started so it's a bit of
background I actually saw one of the
winners on the Wednesday videos and I
think it was on Leslie's service
accommodation and I I wish I got in
touch with her and found out a bit more
about half about property and we thought
we really need to do this and yeah we've
got some contacts in Asia we've got some
contacts in UK and and we can really
make this work yeah how about we get
quit our jobs go back to UK and just
just dive just jump straight into it big
decision that exactly our families are
still still there yeah so yeah so he
told me about it and I watch to have oh
hey hang on I've actually got my own HMO
property which I've had since 2006 okay
and I thought hey I could do I could be
doing the same thing but I was I hate
you a property in England in England in
hand field I'm making a good profit yeah
it's not too bad so back then the
property was I was on for 210,000 I'm
now getting around 1600 a month only for
ten months but still it's okay okay a
silly place right in place in Hatfield
right next to the other house about 350
okay so it's almost doubled in value
most yeah okay so yeah you see got a
little bit of property experience there
you making some money but they new
studio Hong Kong working as I was a
financial planner
okay Hong Kong so selling insurance and
savings and just managing other
finances basically and what's your link
are you business problems friends family
so we've we're brothers and so where do
we get both our exes within the company
sure yeah just-just-just I sell
ourselves young so what happened then so
you come to England you come to the
crash course yes I came to the crash
course and Wow
like we love so much we I think we we
were stuck we never really attended any
property training courses and the energy
within the crash course of it was in set
what is amazing there's so many people
to network with we learn about return on
investments all the different investment
strategies including lease options we
learn how to sort of contact estate
agents you made us cool laughing yeah
made ourselves a really uncomfortable
but we've got cops of all learning from
that experience everything starts at the
crash course but it is so true
everything does start there you meet new
friends you learn new skills and yeah
the crash course was where it all began
and then we basically just picked up
pace from there I mean Jason has been on
the DfE and never use your money again
courses but from their pace has really
picked up since yeah March basically so
let's just look at where we're at now I
know you guys are taking the world by
storm what you achieve then since that
crash course earlier this year
financially property wise what's
happened so so see it's a crash course
which was yeah February I think it was
about February 22nd it was yeah yeah
what I literally landed on the 20th so
went straight to the crash course and
then from there we picked up our first
source bill yeah it was a rental service
accommodation it was a 3-bedroom house
in Cambridge and we fixed that up we did
everything ourselves
yeah it was this one that you you rented
to rent out yes yes yes I rent to rent
rent to si yeah yeah we paid for that
deal and we decided to do the
renovations ourselves all the painting
all the work inside yeah furnishings and
and it took us just under three weeks
okay and how much money did you put it
down in total for that - you know to do
it up the deposit just the the fee in
total so the sourcing theme was a three
and a half thousand okay
bit pricey in terms of renovation it was
a free bedroom house we get we basically
completed the whole project for slightly
over five grand
yeah it's all in maybe eight and a half
and that's quite a lot of money to put
down on a property that you don't own
right of course yeah yeah but how does
it have to go now now so yeah that was
that took us about three weeks yeah our
first full month was in April yeah we
made profit of slightly over one and a
half I was a very very strong but in
April in May it was slightly over 2
grand and then the profit again and then
in June we amazingly got a 1:1 booking
for the whole month you know there's a
tenant in there right now waiting for
the whole month and that's gonna make us
two-and-a-half grand profit that's
incredible
okay the sauce is almost kick yourself
now for not keeping it no no we're still
in contact with them and then they're
very happy for us so we keep on asking
me have you got more deals like this but
your own deals like that yes so what
else have you done staff tur that deal
so since then we've also managed to
source our own bills and we've been on
obviously your training
yeah we've learned how to yes get in
contact with landlords live contouring
or other methods yeah and yeah it was a
director landlord deal it's a
two-bedroom penthouse in Cambridge nice
and even there even better was that the
landlord mentioned there was five other
people that actually approached her but
they decided to give us a deal because
we obviously had more we knew what words
to say how to react and how to present
ourselves than a paper efficient that's
the thing that so many people trying to
do right to rent that they don't know
the correct contracts to use they don't
know about the the legalities and the
compliance of it they don't carry
themself well a
have to sell speaks people so you know
bones when you come along yes and you've
got the Asian charisma but more
importantly you've got the right
knowledge the right that you sang the
right things you use the absolutely
streets ahead similar yeah and yes she
she gave us the bill and yet with us
just gone live for slightly less than
two weeks now yeah and we've turned over
around for you for K it's incredible
so you've clearly got a knack for
finding these ready to rent deals and
knowing what works and what doesn't I
mean sometimes you don't hear the
stories of the rents and deals that go
wrong but then it happens it does happen
but it's an early cycle deals that fall
through or they take them on a lot
really down and then they can't read
them out in a way that they thought how
do you know from all your experience and
all that you've learned in doing this
over the past few months how do you
identify the difference between a good
deal in a bad deal the due diligence as
we always say most important you've got
to do your research you're gonna know
the area and sometimes you might get it
wrong but if the more research you do
the less likely you're gonna screw up
and education as we've always been
saying is the main thing so if you don't
know the area you pay to get that info
either through someone who who's based
in that area or just physically going to
that area speaking to this their agents
finding out what demand is like in
certain areas north of that city or town
could also have it actually also from
your training you've also advised us to
have an exit strategy yeah so I think
it's really important like what we did
with the first house that was a
three-bedroom house basically we've got
the third property coming along as well
so we're picking up the keys later today
and that was my rent yeah that was a
four-bedroom house director estate agent
yeah again for building up that Network
and playing in cars right yeah we if
anything goes wrong if there was any
changes we've got yeah like a position
in a pan be like a break for instance
yeah editing out in a different way yeah
oh yeah we could rent them out as
individual rooms
yeah I'm still making money yeah we've
got a back-up plan so yeah I think I
think that's really important from the
training and you guys that's great I
think what you got to do it is fantastic
tell me a bit about I know you've got a
lot of people back home in Hong Kong who
are interested in property as well and I
wanted to come and invest in England's
what what's the best thing to do for a
Hong Kong investor that doesn't know the
English market at all how do you break
into the UK market as a Hong Kong
investor well I think for any foreign
investor whether they're from Hong Kong
or any other part of the world they
really do need someone who they can
trust yeah who knows the market well and
certain areas which are a good return on
investment because at the end of the day
it's a business for us it's an
investment for them they need to make
sure that their money is being well
spent
so yeah we were born in the UK but we've
been away for new I've been away for ten
years Jason's been away for seven so you
know that you know that you came really
well yeah I think we're ahead no no I
think we're in a great position because
we both grew up in the UK we both bought
our properties here so Kenya is housed
in I've got my two bedroom flat in
Stratford yeah in London and we both
very aware of the process of buying a
house in UK yeah and then we also
managed to buy our properties in Hong
Kong so we're really yet with word
knowledge rapport both sides of the
market and also the returns in the
capital appreciation that you could get
from Hong Kong as well yeah and at the
moment like prices are ridiculously high
and yeah if you really want your money
to grow and to get a good cash flow from
it then UK investing in HMOs like you
you teach people yeah that's a fantastic
opportunity what's the market like in
Hong Kong for a new bill you're looking
at maybe two and a half thousand per
square foot so that's 25,000 pounds yeah
a square metre so your typical
two-bedroom 400 foot
square 454 flat is about 450,000 half
mil
yeah expenses that's London prices yeah
so that's all over Hong Kong yeah
obviously when you reach up to the mid
levels or more prominent areas yeah
you're looking at double that I know you
get a lot of people from Hong Kong
reaching out to you guys for advice and
stuff like that and you often support
which is cry would you recommend
investing in Hong Kong or is it just not
feasible how would I get on doing the FF
challenge in Hong Kong we were watching
the financial freedom challenge and we
know how to sum you were doing Hong Kong
yes it's it's a really tough market
obviously the language is slightly did
you have a lot there's a lot of Hong
Kong investors that come to the crash
course yes yeah I think we had a few on
the crash course that we went that's
people flying in yeah but she's just why
do you think people do that why don't I
fly it in I mean I know the classical is
good but why what why didn't that
happens I think we're prophecy if
they're even getting that four percent
from their bite of that they're happy
yeah so if you're telling them invest in
an HMO I'm offering the Midlands in the
UK you're gonna get 20% or however much
return on investment that's gonna that's
gonna attract them they'll take a trip
yeah because honestly this
Hong Kong is one of them places where we
get most of our overseas people come
yeah I'm thinking I did a crash course
in Hong Kong maybe you could join me
oh you guys they are glutton I think
you've got a lot really well that I'd
love to you but I think also it's the is
the barriers to entry which is also an
issue like I said if a flat is
four-and-a-half oh it's four and a half
million dollars which is about 450,000
sterling the deposit you would need is
about 30% yo in order to have that sort
of money a regular working person yeah
struggles
whereas in the UK if you can still buy a
property for say 150
yep your 30% boy would over anything
what did you recommend someone's doing
then if they're living in Hong Kong and
they've got say 50,000 pounds obviously
in their bank it would okay
different currency would they be better
off to buy HMO or to do rent events like
what would your advice be I think it
really does depend on the individual
investor if they're looking for good
cash flow then rent si would be a good
idea but in terms of stability and long
term investments yeah I think HMOs is
the way to go for them yeah it really
does depend on the individual investors
I know that on our trailing renter rent
is just one one one small part of a
strategy of what we teach have you
applied or are you going to apply any of
the other stuff around investments and
property entrepreneurship that you've
learned on the crash course are the deal
finding extravaganza yes of course
so we've already sell our bill sourcing
company brilliant how's that go at the
moment here we're still finding the
perfect patch although yet you spent two
to long finding yeah you got to get
these in my area
exactly you wouldn't you can't sell
something to someone else unless you
bought yourself right okay yeah yeah and
yeah we're beyond viewings but yeah
we're trying to find the deals and then
package it up and sell it
so our investors right yeah that's the
next step of the business and what are
you long-term goals wait long to involve
in property your brothers you're both
quit your jobs you technican financially
free I mean just right I mean the fact
that you're making up you act in a
full-time income more than yeah in
promised a new song is absolutely
commendable what are your long-term what
are you on 10 girls yes so we really
want to saw obviously yeah people
working on the sa side of a business at
the same time we really want to start on
the deal sourcing and actually yes pass
on these ills these amazing deals that
you could get in the UK so my agent
invested
south in Hong Kong China what color
deals are you looking to pass out mainly
HMOs sure cuz it you're always wanted
strokes enlighten me why if you've got
other side yeah I guess it's probably
because you put down eight grand for one
deal so but I get a second what we only
put in one room rural area and it's
making yeah we're already making turning
over three four okay Wow Winston my
question is if people are packaging and
selling rent to sa deals why would they
pass it on when they could just keep it
themself and it's so little money now
because there's a lot of management on
the handling of the bookings yeah the
day-to-day running with the cleaners
because at the moment yeah we're still
handling ourselves I think as we grow
and maybe hit about four or five sure
warehouse source that side to turn and
so people people might be thinking you
know what this is going to take a few
thousand pounds rather than spending a
few thousand and then get a really good
return I'd rather pass on the
opportunity and just get some quick cash
or it might be a case of I've already
got five or six I don't really want
anymore essays I manage them myself but
I'm not it nice to set up yeah I guess I
guess that makes sense okay cool so what
would be the biggest if you were talking
to someone who was just brand new to
poverty that was looking at doing red
tomatoes like what you've done you
pretty much I mean I know you have some
experience in property because you
bought hate em oh yeah but red turmeric
was a new and brand new thing to sighs
have you heard of it before
you still spotted watching my videos
we'd heard of subletting which is
obviously not the right way to go about
it yeah I mean my previous investment
experience is very amateur if I would
call it that because I bought the house
I let the agent take care of it and I
didn't know anything about it basically
yeah other than you know some of bolt
needed changing all the locks needed
changing and they asked me whether it's
okay it's go ahead with it but now this
time around it's more hands-on and
getting the proper finding the property
fire ass or so or the landlord or the
estate agents yeah and we've been quite
fortunate to be able to do all three and
have experience of the three different
ways of finding a property in terms of
investing in essays you know we all know
that it's not all rose
yeah there are a lot of pitfalls our
love issues with getting one running one
yeah keeping it going and keeping the
standards dance well it's like any
business yeah it's always gonna have
it's gonna have its its its obstacles
and its hardships what's been the
biggest challenge that you've had then
with with running your sa business
service accommodation I think it's
actually more yeah you should slowly
move actually from property to
hospitality yes you're trying to
actually yeah constantly make sure the
service is really up to scratch yeah the
reviews are so important as you will
know then and yeah like one bad review
and then yeah you could get a drop in
bookings and yeah I think trying to
control the hospitality side and at the
same time trying to grow your business
up it is it was the challenge yeah that
we're sort of facing everyone but at the
moment we're hitting 80% occupancy so
very very hard I mean in regards to
areas you've chosen Cambridge would you
add a source or recommend in the in the
air areas if you don't much have you
done much research on England or the UK
as a whole or we just literally
Cambridge and that's right to sa we
thought we know the area we know this
high demand and it's working yeah I
think yeah I think the idea was the
rental essay was just to supplement our
our previous income yeah get us going so
we could further refocus on property
sourcing and yeah buy refurbished
recliner how does it feel to be
full-time in property in the UK it's
amazing I'll honesty oh yeah quickly my
job and and diving straight into this
it's been being your own bosses
yeah gives you so much freedom I've I've
always been in sales in terms of my
working life and my previous job working
as a financial adviser I was
self-employed so I working for myself as
my own boss but if what it's not quite
the same as being in property because
property is tangible it's I'm working
for myself now rather than for someone
else yeah and you know I'm still
applying a lot of the the concepts of my
insurance sales to property well
because yeah people skills I guess yes
absolutely only comes from people yeah
in any business yeah I mean the property
might sell itself but ultimately is the
people who make the difference so if
they don't like you they may not want to
talk to you yeah any further so yeah
they've got it like you you've got to be
able to connect to people and and know
what they want so when we speak to other
be a landlord be an investor we've got
to know what they want we've got to
provide the solution to their problem
yeah before we can actually have any
sort of business deal will be the
biggest lesson it if you were advising
your your 12 month younger selves that
were in Hong Kong about to go on the
crash course what will be the biggest
lesson that you'd give them an advice so
I've got whether it's your book or as
this book was I've read the line the
best things in life is on the other side
of fear yeah yeah absolutely every time
you take a really risky decision yeah it
you find a way to work it out
you'll find the solution to every
problem and yeah and so far isn't it's
got to be obstacles in everyday life and
yeah we've been operatives well and
taking massive risk you know the fact
that you've left your jobs or businesses
and you've moved country on the faces
that you're gonna go out and do property
yeah it's worked for you you've landed
on your feet because you've got the
right training and you've taken to my
action and you know the right belief
yeah you know right from the get-go I
remember at the DfE I remember with
yourself Jason you know your mentalities
both of you is very much just like this
is gonna happen yeah it's not a case of
you know some people they go on the
crash course and they cross my fingers
like on it I'm I going to be crushed
cause I hope this work but it's not
about I hope it does work yeah this
works but you have to work yeah it is
not a lottery ticket
now you happen and you guys came from
Hong Kong like this is gonna work we're
gonna do this but we're just going to
help get resourced and get tools to help
us along on the journey which we're
gonna do anyway you kind of feel like
and I know you you know you're humble
guys and your credit manager
which of course I know that's quite a
massive part but the bottom line is
you've stepped out and you we've owned
actually dove
this is what we're gonna do yeah and
when you do that the right people just
get little slides or any well I'd like
to think that as well I think another
bit of advice if I was to give myself or
the other person yeah like 12 months ago
is to keep it simple and be simple
minded because the more you think about
it the less likely you're going to do it
because there's so much self-doubt
embedded in us and in everyday lives
basically so like I say if you want to
do it just say yes and then think of how
are you gonna do it yeah you got to
believe in yourself that's what your
browser says that if an opportunity
presents itself say yes then figure the
details later and you guys are clearly
living testimonies of that just figure
it out so that's right and also yeah
just immerse yourself into property yeah
really just told people what we're gonna
do and yeah announced on Facebook about
we're gonna quit our jobs I'm going to
go back to UK - yes and so many contacts
of like just come through and basically
we're doomed
joint ventures with them I had a
colleague cause I used to be an
accountant and yet basically I was he
was in the Treasury team we work
together and it turns out that he's now
a chartered surveyor and he's got an
architect that works with him and we're
doing a Jamie together for a nottingham
project was a refurbishing of a
commercial property right and yeah our
uncle my uncle who owns quite a few
commercial properties
he sort of mentioned about what well he
didn't know what to do with this
property and weeds or got in touch and
now we're doing we're going to do we
were submitting the planning an
application now and we're going to
convert that into a six - hug the eight
bedroom ya-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-h arm is
you have two bedroom apartments oh wow
massive so currently it's a three storey
I think it was at Expo yeah a single
storey like kind of storage area
potentially that could be four stories
high and two separate parts on each
level that's correct so yeah
that's the question with the training
that you've done on the crash ball still
filing extravaganza what have been the
biggest sort of takeaways the biggest
lessons that you've you've learned again
yes take action yeah and yeah because I
literally force you to book news and
stuff exactly I think most people have
probably not done that because I mean if
you've bought a property oh you put your
in viewer that you owe you go in there
to buy but this time around is
completely different and you're looking
for yeah you might be buying it in the
end but you don't really know and yeah a
little bit say on that on the deal fall
extravaganza he who books the most
viewings wins him who puts the most
offers in wins and you've done that I
mean you you've done absolutely
phenomenally well so I think it's great
to see you smashing it I hope you see
you continue and I wish you all the best
fit with you of the different vendors
and stuff that you've got on and great
thanks much for coming on the show
thanks so much
awesome thank you Jason thank you can't
thank you your job if you are from Hong
Kong Asia or overseas and you think you
can I really do this is this possible
you've seen it yourself firsthand it
absolutely is possible so get yourself
booked on some trainings watch more
stories be inspired to take action and
look for to seeing you next time
[Music]